bon on va pas faire mystère vous avez vu
le titre de la vidéo donc on sait tous
pourquoi vous êtes là merci de ton aide
GG donc oui le sexe effectivement les
aphrodisiaques pour être précis ce qui
marche ce qui marche pas voilà donc on
va pas sortir pendant des heures on va y
aller on sait tous de quoi on va parler
tu es lourd
[Musique]
un petit message avant de commencer
cette vidéo est sponsorisée par les lots
les lots vous les connaissez maintenant
si vous me suivez régulièrement et
peut-être même si vous me suivez pas
régulièrement mais juste parce que vous
les connaissez c'est une marque de sex
toys une marque de sextoys haut de gamme
c'est-à-dire efficace c'est important
mais aussi solide esthétique et surtout
fabriqué dans des matériaux de qualité
qui respectent vos muqueuses le plaisir
et la sécurité avant tout c'est aussi
une marque qui partage mes valeurs en
termes de sexualité positive et pour moi
ça c'est important aussi et il se trouve
qu'en ce moment les lots fêtent c'est 20
ans
[Musique]
les lots et pour fêter dignement les 20
ans de vélo il y a deux trois trucs qui
vont vous intéresser d'abord il y a
plein de promo super intéressantes sur
leur site je vous remets l'adresse dans
la description de cette vidéo vous y
restez un œil ça vaut le coup ça va
quand même jusqu'à moins 50 %. j'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que vous allez
trouver votre bonheur parce qu'il y en a
pour tous les goûts rien que parmi leurs
petits nouveaux déjà ça par exemple
c'est un stimulateur clitoridien son
petit nez de musaraigne là il lui permet
d'être hyper précis
vous voyez le vous voyez celui-là c'est
un stimulateur prostatique avec aussi
une partie qui stimule le périnée là
encore j'imagine que vous visualisez
et en plus des sextoys vous allez
trouver tout ce qu'il faut pour vous en
servir correctement genre du lubrifiant
très important ça de bien lubrifier et
puis aussi du spray nettoyant par
exemple l'hygiène très important aussi
ça donc il y a plein de choses vous
allez voir vous allez trouver de quoi
vous satisfaire mais surtout à tous
seigneur tout honneur vous allez aussi
trouver le petit dernier le petit
dernier il est très spécial parce que
c'est la toute dernière version
améliorée du tout premier toy historique
de l'ELO c'est aussi un stimulateur
clitoridien mais plus compact donc vous
pouvez l'emmener partout pour pouvoir
vous en servir où vous voulez et avec
qui vous voulez et pour fêter son 20e
anniversaire les lots le fait à tout
petit prix pendant toute l'année 2023
vous avez tous les renseignements sur
leur site je vous laisse aller voir mais
vous le savez maintenant je vous laisse
jamais repartir sans un petit cadeau et
cette fois vous allez pouvoir gagner
l'un des trois toys que je viens de vous
montrer si vous voulez participer au
concours allez dans les commentaires de
cette vidéo et écrivez je veux un toy
stp
exactement comme ça ensuite on fera le
tirage au sort et on verra un toy au
gagnant mais revenons-en aux
aphrodisiaques un litre d'huile de
carottes 1 d'huile de radis et un quart
d'huile de moutarde tu mets le rat un
demi-litre de fourmi jaune safran
vivante tu ajouteras d'accord l'huile au
soleil 4 jours tu exposeras alors 4 à 2h
avant coït avec l'huile prête à l'emploi
le pénis tu viendra
du vert vous moindre et après bah après
clairement rien du tout parce que
personne va vouloir de ta vieille
gluante pleine de cadavre du ménoptère
ça
pas une chance ce que je viens de vous
donner là c'est une recette créée par un
dénommé Maïmonide un philosophe
théologien et médecin du 12e siècle
voilà c'était juste pour planter le
décor pour vous montrer que les
aphrodisiaques bah non seulement c'est
pas un truc qui date d'hier mais en plus
que les conseils ont la matière ça a
toujours été un peu disons intrigant oui
parce que vous allez voir que ça c'est
pas beaucoup arrangé depuis mais déjà on
va se mettre d'accord sur les termes
parce que c'est pas si clair que ça
définition du Petit Robert aphrodisiaque
qui excite ou est censé exciter le désir
sexuel voilà on sent bien que même du
côté du dico on est un peu réservé sur
l'efficacité du truc mais déjà on peut
remarquer un truc dans l'absolu donc un
aphrodisiaque c'est censé stimuler le
désir pourtant il suffit de chercher le
mot sur internet pour se rendre compte
que
et puis aussi que
voir carrément
bon c'est pas si clair parce que non
tout ça c'est pas la même chose le désir
c'est quelque chose qu'on éprouve pour
une personne en particulier ou plusieurs
mais bref la libido enfin courant pas au
sens psychanalytique parce que Freud là
les vidéos c'est la recherche du plaisir
sexuel vous voyez la nuance peu importe
le la ou les partenaires et puis
l'érection bon bah vous voyez à peu près
mais déjà ça exclut de fait toute une
partie des personnes concernées par la
sexualité même si tous les organes
génitaux ont des érections là on sent
bien que c'est les tennis qui sont visés
quand même mais de toute façon il peut y
avoir du désir mais pas d'érection et à
l'inverse il peut y avoir une érection
mais pas de désir on va pas développer
ça maintenant mais ce que je vous
propose c'est d'en reparler dans une
prochaine vidéo sur les troubles de
l'érection oui parce que j'ai
l'intention de lancer une série de
vidéos sur la santé sexuelle n'hésitez
pas à me dire dans les commentaires si
ça vous intéresse ou pas
je sais pas je demande et bien sûr on
parlera pas que d'érection pour le coup
là il y en aura vraiment pour tout le
monde bref vous allez me dire oui non
mais ça c'est la définition du Petit
Robert c'est pas très scientifique quand
même ça
ok admettons voyons ce qu'on dit un
dictionnaire médical alors aphrodisiaque
qui a la propriété de rendre plus
intense les plaisirs de l'amour se dit
des substances qui produisent ou sont
censés stimuler le désir sexuel et
permettre la réalisation de l'acte
sexuel bon ok c'est vrai que là ça a
l'air d'englober plus de trucs mais
notez bien quand même qu'on est encore
un petit peu frileux sur l'efficacité du
truc on est encore sur du c'est censé
stimuler en tout cas le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que le terme est assez
flou la seule chose en vrai sur laquelle
tout le monde s'accorde c'est que ça
vient du nom de la déesse Aphrodite la
déesse de l'amour et de la beauté mais
aussi du plaisir et de la procréation en
fait à priori le terme il est apparu au
18e siècle mais manifestement les
humains ont toujours utilisé des
substances pour tenter de booster leur
désirs ou d'améliorer leur performances
sexuelles même à l'époque où le mot
aphrodisiaque n'existe pas et le mot
booster non plus d'ailleurs par exemple
on a retrouvé dans des grottes en Irak
des plantes qui sont censées être
aphrodisiaques et qui ont été déposés là
il y a plus de 60 000 ans on n'est pas
complètement sûr de pourquoi il les
utilisaient à l'époque évidemment mais
on peut quand même penser que bon ce
dont on est à peu près sûr par contre
c'est que on a retrouvé un truc sur un
papyrus qui date de 1550 ans avant notre
ère et que ce truc c'est une ordonnance
pour un aphrodisiaque une recette on
n'est pas sûr que ça marchait par contre
ça ça bouge pas bon mais ok on va dire
que un aphrodisiaque c'est un truc qui
stimule un peu tout ce qui est sexuel on
va pas essayer d'être beaucoup plus
précis que ça mais est-ce que ça marche
c'est quand même ça la question ce que
je vous propose dans un premier temps
c'est de passer en revue les
aphrodisiaques les plus fréquemment
cités et de voir ce dont l'efficacité a
été prouvé scientifiquement allez c'est
parti le gingembre le ginseng le ginko
le ginto non pardon je sais pas je vais
tentais un truc le piment les épices le
bois bandé les huîtres les fraises le
miel les avocats les graines de courge
la figue noire les asperges le Tribulus
la Maca la Macarena
[Musique]
Rena bah oui la vérité c'est que aucune
étude scientifique n'a jamais démontré
qu'aucun de ces aliments n'était
véritablement aphrodisiaques d'ailleurs
aphrodisiaque c'est même pas une notion
scientifique c'est plutôt une notion
marketing un truc pour faire vendre donc
quand vous lisez ça
alors attention je vous entends d'ici
effectivement que ça veut dire que ça
marche pas
voilà il y en a peut-être même un ou
deux qui vont me sortir des études plus
ou moins obscures genre une étude qui
montre que le gingembre ça dilate un peu
les vaisseaux donc ça favorise le flux
sanguin donc ça favorise les érections
ou une autre qui montre que le miel ça
stimule la sécrétion de dopamine et que
comme la dopamine ça a un rôle dans
l'excitation sexuelle bah du coup le
miel a un rôle dans l'équitation
sexuelle bon admettons mais là a priori
on parle quand même pas d'effets qui
sont suffisamment significatifs pour
avoir une vraie influence sur le désir
l'excitation sexuelle ou les érections
je dis pas que ça à zéro est fait je dis
que 1 ça a pas été prouvé que ça en
avait et que deux même si ça en a ne
serait-ce qu'un effet placebo parce que
c'est un vrai effet a priori ça n'a
jamais permis à personne de régler le
problème pour lequel il en avait pris
d'ailleurs est-ce que vous avez déjà
entendu quelqu'un dire ah tiens tu sais
il y a un après-midi j'étais au boulot
je buvais une petite tisane gingembre
miel et tout d'un coup
je me suis retrouvé
sur la photocopieuse c'était ouf mais
bon oui c'est vrai de tous les temps aux
quatre coins du monde dans toutes les
civilisations on a toujours utilisé des
aphrodisiaques des plantes donc comme on
a vu là avec pour but principal soit de
donner de la vigueur soit de renforcer
l'excitation sexuelle mais aussi bien
souvent de se défoncer puisque pour
faire ce genre de préparation suivant
les pays on a longtemps utilisé du
chanvre de la coca ou du peyote par
exemple le peyote c'est pas un
dessinateur de BD c'est un cactus dont
on tire la mescaline qui est impuissante
hallucinogène tout ça c'est ni plus ni
moins que l'ancêtre du Ken sexe même
s'il a encore le terme n'existait pas à
l'époque je sais pas si vous connaissez
le Game sexe masque pareil on en
reparlera dans une prochaine vidéo si ça
vous intéresse mais pour ces fameuses
préparations aphrodisiaques on sépare
cantonais au végétaux évidemment vous
vous doutez bien qu'on n'était pas vegan
du à l'époque donc oui on avait et on a
même encore maintenant des trucs
d'origine animale avec différentes
propriétés supposées comme par exemple
la mouche espagnole qu'on appelle aussi
La cantaride alors on lit beaucoup de
choses au sujet de la cantarine et
notamment que réduit en poudre et avaler
est provoquerait des érections mais
plutôt des érections genre
inflammatoires donc assez douloureuses
et surtout avec un certain nombre de
risques de complications plus ou moins
graves on lit aussi que un certain
nombre de personnages historiques comme
Richelieu ou le marquis de Sade par
exemple l'aurait utilisé dans un certain
nombre de conditions qui ressemblent pas
mal à de la soumission chimique mais
d'un point de vue purement usage
aphrodisiaque on entend dire aussi que
c'est ce qui aurait tué Félix Faure vous
savez le président français qui est mort
pendant un rapport sexuel avec sa
maîtresse bon là encore difficile de
démêler le vrai du faux par contre rien
à voir mais j'ai découvert que la poudre
de cantarine ça entre aussi dans la
composition du Racer la noute je sais
pas vous mais perso après un couscous je
me transforme rarement en furie sexuel
en tout cas cette poudre elle est encore
vendue à l'heure actuelle comme
aphrodisiaque dans la série des
aphrodisiaques d'origine animale comment
ne pas citer la fameuse poudre de de
rhinocéros qui n'a jamais non plus fait
la preuve de favoriser quoi que ce soit
à part le braconnage et le trafic qui
met en danger la survie de l'espèce même
chose pour l'holocurie le concombre de
mer à qui on prête des vertus
aphrodisiaques sans aucune preuve et qui
du coup est menacé à cause de la pêche
illégale vous allez remarqué non et si
la forme des trucs soit disant
aphrodisiaque et bon d'accord ça marche
un peu moins bien pour le gingembre mais
pour les autres on est d'accord quand
même non
c'est quand même sur des trucs très très
phalliques non et attendez il y a pire
pour améliorer notre sexualité des fois
c'est pas juste des trucs qui
ressemblent à des pénis qu'on nous
conseille de manger
[Musique]
mangeons directement des pénis ou des
testicules d'animaux pas de tigre de
cerf de cheval de mouton dan de chien
etc etc et devinez quoi
ça menace certaines espèces le tigre par
exemple bon je crois que ce coup-là on
peut se l'avouer assez clairement si
quand on parle d'aphrodisiaque on a
cette impression dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure qu'on oublie une bonne moitié
des gens qui sont concernés par tout ce
qui concerne la sexualité c'est quand
même parce que tout ça c'est très très
accès pénis on tue quand même des
animaux pour avoir le zizi dur et en
plus ça marche même pas peut-être qu'on
s'y prend pas bien peut-être qu'on prend
pas les choses comme il faut au sens
figuré je veux dire plus de pas
seulement mais bon concrètement puisque
c'est ça que vous voulez savoir
qu'est-ce qui marche vraiment sans avoir
besoin de manger des trucs chelous et
sans effets secondaires on va reprendre
les choses à la base le but quand on
prend un aphrodisiaque c'est de créer
les conditions idéales pour avoir un
rapport sexuel satisfaisant pour tout le
monde alors déjà il faut se poser la
question de ce que c'est vraiment un
rapport sexuel satisfaisant pour tout le
monde mais ça on va y revenir dans un
premier temps au niveau de notre corps
c'est quoi les bonnes conditions et ben
on en a déjà parlé dans la vidéo sur
l'orgasme que je vous chaudement à aller
voir ou revoir entre le premier oeil qui
frise et le bouquet final il se passe
tout un tas de choses dans notre
organisme et il y a notamment une
multitude d'hormones et de substances
diverses qui se mettent en branle pour
faire monter la tyrance le désir
l'excitation sexuelle et préparer à la
fois notre corps et notre esprit à ce
qui va suivre je vais pas vous refaire
la liste complète de toutes ces
substances mais sachez juste qu'on
sécrète tout ça naturellement pas besoin
d'avaler de la poudre de Mushu de la
soupe de zizi pour ça concrètement au
niveau physiologique il y a deux moyens
d'augmenter le désir stimuler la
sécrétion de ces substances quand on
vient de parler et diminuer la sécrétion
d'autres substances qui vont avoir
l'effet inverse pour différentes raisons
on est d'accord qu'il y a pas que
l'aspect physiologique qui entre en
compte il y a aussi l'aspect
psychologique évidemment mais comme on
le dit à chaque fois tout est lié et en
l'occurrence vous allez vite comprendre
pourquoi ben oui parce qu'en réalité
tout ce dont on parle là ça se passe
essentiellement au niveau d'une de nos
principales zones érogènes l'organe
sexuel dont on parle le moins le cerveau
alors ces aphrodisiaques qui sont
vraiment efficaces et qui nous mettent
dans les bonnes conditions pour un
rapport sexuel satisfaisant pour tout le
monde c'est quoi le premier c'est le
consentement ça va sans dire mais ça va
toujours mieux en le disant et puis si
vraiment ça allait sans dire ça saurait
donc la base le consentement tout le
monde est d'accord sur ce qui va se
passer et pas se passer tout le monde a
le droit de demander tout le monde a le
droit de refuser et tout le monde a le
droit de changer d'avis en cours de
route ça c'est l'aphrodisiaque le plus
puissant dans le sens où c'est la
condition sinequanone pour être dans les
bonnes conditions psychiques et donc
physique à avoir un rapport sexuel dans
la mesure où de toute façon pas de
consentement égal pas de rapport sexuels
donc ça c'est réglé attention chez
certaines personnes tout ce qui est
rapport de domination ça va stimuler
toutes nos petites substances de
l'excitation là dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure donc évidemment c'est ok mais
pour tout ça comme pour tout le reste
faut que tout le monde soit d'accord
là-dessus au départ et prévoir un
safware dos espèce de mot de passe qui
permet de tout arrêter dès qu'on
prononce voilà maintenant que c'est
clair laissez-moi vous parler d'un autre
aphrodisiaque extrêmement puissant le
lâcher prise lâcher prise ça veut pas
dire perdre le contrôle complètement et
faire n'importe quoi lâcher prise ça
veut juste dire ne pas se mettre la
pression lâcher prise ça vous permet
deux choses être dans les meilleures
conditions pour être à votre propre
écoute et à l'écoute de l'autre et ça
permet aussi de vous mettre à l'abri des
substances dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure vous savez celle qui ont l'effet
inverse des bonnes hormones ces
substances c'est celle qui sont au moins
en partie responsable d'une grande
majorité des pannes ou des troubles
sexuels ces substances c'est ce qu'on
appelle les hormones du stress comme le
cortisol par exemple et nous pourrissent
la vie quand on se met la pression quand
on a peur quand on est inquiet etc le
stress c'est le pire ennemi du sexe donc
il faut se détendre et pour ça il faut
lâcher prise d'ailleurs c'est sûrement
pour ça que depuis des millénaires les
gens utilisent des drogues pour ça vous
souvenez le keme sexe dont je parlais
tout à l'heure en gros utiliser des
drogues pour se mettre en condition
avant d'avoir un rapport sexuel le
problème c'est que même si ça désigne
même si ça détend même si ça enlève la
pression dans l'immense majorité des cas
ça a des conséquences physiques qui
nuisent à l'acte sexuel le meilleur
exemple celui qui va sans doute parler
au plus grand nombre de gens parce que
c'est la drogue la plus utilisée c'est
l'alcool ok l'alcool ça rend chaud ça
rend chaud mais on perd en qualité au
niveau des érections voir on perd les
érections tout court ça diminue la
lubrification vaginale et surtout ça
limite toutes les sensations parce qu'au
niveau neurologique ça anesthésie un
petit peu tout le corps pas ouf on est
d'accord donc le mieux c'est de faire
100 d'autant plus qu'il y a un tas
d'autres raisons dont on reparlera dans
une autre vidéo alors vous allez me dire
oui mais quand on lâche prise on est un
peu vulnérable non et c'est là
qu'intervient le troisième aphrodisiaque
le plus puissant la confiance pour
lâcher prise il faut être en confiance
en confiance avec l'autre histoire par
exemple d'être sûr qu'il ou elle va pas
nous juger sur votre physique sur nos
envies sur nos limites sur nos
performances etc et donc tout ça ça
implique aussi d'avoir un minimum
confiance en soi alors ça c'est
clairement pas le plus facile mais un
bon début c'est justement d'en finir
avec cette fameuse notion de performance
on n'est pas dans un porno on n'est pas
dans une épreuve sportive il y a pas de
figure imposées il y a pas de timing
imposé il y a rien d'imposer en fait il
y a juste deux personnes qui ont envie
de donner et de prendre du plaisir et
qui vont se mettre d'accord sur la façon
dont elles ont envie d'y arriver et si
cette façon ça marche pas pour une
raison X ou Y bah la bonne nouvelle
c'est que il y a 1000 autres façons donc
pas de souci conséquence directe de tout
ça le quatrième aphrodisiaque qui a fait
ses preuves et dont j'ai envie de vous
parler la communication c'est ce qui lit
tous les autres aphrodisiaques dont on a
parlé avant pour être sûr que tout le
monde est d'accord faut communiquer pour
dire ce dont on a envie ou pas pour
savoir ce dont l'autre a envie ou pas
faut communiquer la communication c'est
le seul moyen pour que l'autre sache ce
que vous avez dans la tête et
réciproquement et puis la communication
ça permet aussi d'ajuster les choses
c'est l'autre lubrifiant si vous voulez
alors juste un truc la communication
elle est pas uniquement verbale ça passe
pas que par les mots mais disons que les
mots c'est quand même pas mal parce que
c'est quand même la meilleure façon
d'éviter les erreurs d'interprétation
voilà donc des aphrodisiaques qui
marchent vraiment qui vous mettent dans
les meilleures conditions il y en a
d'autres évidemment mais déjà si vous
commencez avec ces quatre là vous partez
sur des bonnes bases alors évidemment il
y a aussi un certain nombre de
médicaments qui sont efficaces pour
traiter un certain nombre de problèmes
comme les troubles de l'érection par
exemple mais là on sort un peu du cadre
des aphrodisiaques et puis comme je vous
l'ai dit tout à l'heure on va en
reparler dans une vidéo dédiée si ça
vous intéresse d'ailleurs si vous avez
des questions si vous avez des sujets
que vous voudriez que je traite dans ma
série de vidéos sur la santé sexuelle
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer tout ça par
mail à question BTC Act gmail.com voilà
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de et prenez
soin des autres mettez-vous bien et
surtout portez-vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]